from unreal tournament bioshock batman
arkham final fantasy 7 remake
to of course fortnite the unreal engine
is the backbone of so many of our
favorite games
let's take a trip down memory lane to
see just how far the game development
technology has come
for all the latest make sure to like
this video and subscribe to gamespot
[Music]
[Music]
unreal engine 3 this light for example
has a cowling that casts soft shadows on
the scene around it
this is accomplished using a light
function in this case
the function takes two cube maps one
very crisp
and the other blurred unreal engine 3
allows total control
over how objects interact with the
environment all of the objects in this
scene
are physically responsive in some way
here we have another lighting function
a stained glass environment that is
being rotated along the cube
because it's a light it both attenuates
and shadows realistically
this particular model is about seventy
five hundred polygons
for the low resolution mesh and about
two million polygons for the high
resolution mesh
many of the smaller details in the high
res mesh like the wrinkles around its
mouth and throat
were hand painted into the normal map
this lets artists at an extra level of
detail
without having to model it by hand we've
done significant work on the character
pipeline
on the left here you see marcus phoenix
as he appears in gears of war
and the right is being rendered in a new
character pipeline you see there's
much greater contrast in the shadows um
much greater
specular lighting bouncing off of the
thing if you remember in gears of war
you fought the locust horde
where the horde consisted of maybe like
five or six locusts
but now we can really build scenes
containing hordes of creatures
besides the realistic water physics
simulation running underneath
we also have realistic specular and
environment reflections bouncing off of
the water
so it captures much more of the
realistic liquidy fuel you see there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
what does jdc day have shown some
fantastic new stuff
starting at digital performance in
unreal engine 4 by andy serkis and you
might know him as gollum from lord of
the rings and hobbit
and if he plays a digital human and it
looks like himself
but he but later you you will see that
this
facial recording can also be used for an
alien-like character
and yeah it has a lot of of usability
thousands of you have asked how our
latest real-time cinematic rebirth was
made
almost not believing that the technology
has come to this point
where photo realism is possible in real
time
but we're here to tell you that finally
photo realism is now not only possible
in real time and for games being made
right now
but that when you use these cutting edge
real-time tools and assets
it's incredibly easy what you see is not
pre-rendered
this is running in real time on a
mainstream gaming computer
with a single 1080 ti not only that
this is a fully interactive world it's
completely playable
i'm just gonna jump into the game here
and have a quick run around the scene
[Music]
so as you can see you can fully interact
with the physics objects of the scene
everything has collisions
if i push this little rock off here it's
going to go falling down
the other great thing that we can do is
change the lighting
full dynamic lighting helps us work much
faster we could also make the most of
unreal engine's volumetric effects
the dynamic lighting really helped us on
our short film it meant that we could
iterate very quickly on our shots
and adjust things in real time this has
to be the right way
[Applause]
before we continue let's stop a moment
and take a look at some of the key
features of this demo
much of what you see was built with
kwixel mega scan assets
but instead of using the game versions
we use the cinematic versions which
would typically only be used in film
there are around a million triangles
each and thanks to virtual texturing
they all use 8k textures as well nanite
can render an insane number of triangles
very quickly
there are over a billion triangles of
source geometry in each frame
that nanite crunches down losslessly to
around 20 million
drawn triangles what does that many
triangles look like
this isn't noise these are the triangles
each a different color
most are so small that they look like
noise nanite achieves detail down to the
pixel
which means triangles are often the size
of pixels
this amount of geometric detail requires
shadows to be pixel accurate as well and
then i can do that too
this swarm of bats was created with a
niagara effect system
particles in niagara can now talk to one
another and understand their environment
like never before
we've also added a ton of new
functionality to run fluid simulations
like you see in the water below
[Music]
the portal is open
don't fail me now
wow
i am a metahuman the next generation of
digital human
powered by unreal engine metahumans are
high fidelity digital characters
created by you the user on our new
content creation platform
metahuman creator i am fully rigged
ready for animation and motion capture
allowing you to work in context
with everything running live and unreal
engine my motion works seamlessly
on other characters i have eight levels
of detail
and have been tested on a wide range of
hardware platforms
from feature film to mobile if you're
interested in learning about my
animation rig
or high fidelity deformations built on
control rig
the new strand based hair system via the
groom component
or how everything is tied together and
animated in sequencer
then have a look under the hood in this
project this
is just a glimpse of things that come
thick
you